hello grammarians hello pain hi David so
Paige have you ever heard of this man
Aldus Manutius I don't think I have
that's a pretty cool name that is his
given name was actually Aldo Manucci oh
he was a venetian printer around 1500
and this guy invented the italic
typeface what yeah so italic is this
this word that really just comes from
Italy right so he's from Venice which is
in modern-day Italy and what it refers
to is text that is kind of on its side
so like this kind of slopes to the right
that's italic and he was one of the
first printers so he had this movable
type printing machine this press and he
developed these letters he cut him into
pieces of metal and he developed this
kind of slanted style and today we call
this the italic typeface Wow
yeah actually technically we'd call this
the italic script because it's based on
an earlier kind of hand from calligraphy
but all the same today we have this
thing in text called italics so okay so
we've got we've got our typeface here
and it comes in two flavors we've got
Roman which is kind of standing right up
and italic which is slanted to the right
page how do we use italics in English
italics have two uses in English one is
to emphasize and the other is to
indicate that something is a title so we
use it for emphasis and titling let's
dive into the first one okay so if we're
trying to use italics to emphasize
something in text we would just use it
to set off one word so for example
that's a really spicy pepper yeah the
word really is said very strongly in
that sentence hmm okay and use case
number two for titling and you know what
to make it easier on ourselves let's um
let's pull up a text box yeah it's kind
of hard to write italics yeah which is
actually going to lead us into another
part of this video you'll see but right
now okay I got my italic type selected
so how did I
those work so if you have a title of
something like book or a movie so okay
so we got a book The Hobbit we're going
to movie and we have a full-length
musical work like a symphony or an album
like Kate Bush's hounds of love like all
of those things can be rendered in
italic and italic type so okay so for
full works then so for books movies and
full-length musical works like an album
or a symphony okay so like a song or a
chapter of a book is not considered a
full word correct okay now as you
pointed out page like the difference
between spicy and really here not the
easiest to discern so if I were going to
be writing out the title of something
just by hand it's pretty hard to do
italics so what we do when we're writing
things by hand is we use the underline
yeah so the underline means the same
thing right as italics you use it for
titles a full works but it's a lot
easier to handwrite and underline than
it is to handwrite italics page what's
your favorite book let's say The Giver
that's a great book that is a great book
all right so I'm writing The Giver
I want to indicate that it's a full
title loop but that underlined
underneath it the giver is Paige's
favorite book
so the way we're the way we're
underlining the giver is the same
functionally as the way we've italicized
the hobbit the thief of the cobbler or
hounds of love that's right so that's
where the italic typeface comes from is
this guy Aldus Manutius
this is how we use it today you can
learn anything Dave it out page out